soweit der russische Außenminister
Sergej lavrov bei mir im Studio ist
Hans-Dieter Heumann der ehemalige
Präsident der Bundesakademie für
Sicherheitspolitik größte
kategorisch die Ukraine zieht den Krieg
unnötig in die Länge der schwarze Peter
liegt bei der Ukraine wie sieht jemand
mit so einer reichen Erfahrung wie Sie
solche Aussagen
er hatte das zu sagen
während das Gipfels in Bali ist schon
schon fast Realitätsverlust denn der
Gipfel in Bali hat er gezeigt dass
Russland
möglicherweise in einer größere
Isolierung kommt als es bisher schon war
ist da raus auch zu verstehen dieses
leichte einschwenken Russlands hinter
den Kulissen dass man sagt okay wir sind
für eine gemeinsame Abschlusserklärung
bereit wir wollen natürlich unsere
Formulierung drinnen behalten aber man
sagt wir haben diese Sicht die anderen
haben diese sichtbar also diesegree
würde man auf der für dich würde ich
schon schärfer sehen
man kann das so ausdrücken da drauf ist
es nicht gelungen eine Erklärung zu
verhindern der wir es ausdrücklich heißt
der meisten
die den Krieg erstmal überhaupt einen
Krieg nennt nicht ein spezialoperationen
wie Russland das selbst tut
bin ich ganz sicher ob sogar der Abzug
russischer Truppen in der Erklärung ist
das weiß ich im Augenblick nicht aber
das so eine Erklärung die die Krieg
ausdrücklich verurteilt
zustande kommt werden auch nicht von
Russland unterschrieben ist ist kein
disagree und auch keinen Kompromiss das
ist
eine eine Niederlage Russlands und jetzt
wird man natürlich sehen wie viel von
den Staaten da
zustimmen die bei früheren Gelegenheiten
vn-abstimmungen und so weiter sich
enthalten haben wenn es um die Frage des
veraltet man gucken wie hat China wie
hat Indien abgestimmt aber auch China
hat ja das ganze laufen lassen hat also
da kein
seinen Partner Russland nicht in Schutz
genommen passierte auf Bali im Moment
was ganz Großes
also ich halte diesen Gipfel für ein
sehr wichtigen
was denn was diesen Ukraine Krieg angeht
und die Stellung Russlands in der Welt
insofern hat das einen globalen
strategischen Aspekt und man muss das
Ganze
Revue passieren lassen gestern das
Treffen was ja vorher geschaltet war das
Treffen zwischen ping und Joe Biden das
finde ich aus zwei Gründen
bedeutend
einmal dass beide Seiten sich bemühen im
Grunde zu entspannen
sie erinnern sich an die ganzen
Voraussagen vor diesem die Spannungen
Taiwan und so weiter beide Führer machen
klar wir wollen nicht wir wollen
entspannen
zum Beispiel sagt beiden wir bleiben bei
der in China-Politik die wird sich nicht
verändern
er sagt auch wir wollen nicht dass die
Wettbewerb glaube ich wörtlich in ein
Konflikt übergeht wir wollen regeln
sagt
und das ist auch ein globaler Ansatz er
sagt wir beide wir beide Großmächte
wir haben eine gemeinsame Verantwortung
also sie können fast sagen hier wird so
eine Art beatpolarität
beschworen gemeinsam Verantwortung bei
den beiden von der ersten und zweiten
wirtschaftsbank der Erde nebenbei gesagt
russlande Nummer 11
und nicht eine multipolare Welt auf die
russland hofft in der es zusammen mit
China sich gegen die USA stellen also
dass dieses Treffen zeigt dass sie dem
pink das eigentlich nicht mehr so
wichtig ist Russland als Partner gegen
die USA zu kriegen man spielt nicht mehr
gegeneinander
ganz hart aus man sagt wir sind ganz
unterschiedlicher Meinung aber man redet
auch miteinander also man redet gut das
ist auch schon bemerkenswert ich glaube
seit fünf Jahren bescheid das für sehr
bemerkenswert weil Zeit zu haben sich
einfach mal die Meinung zu geigen weiß
man ja aus jeder Beziehung Diskussion
ist manchmal sehr wertvoll um einfach
mal selbst wenn man danach nicht weiter
unbedingt an einem Tisch sitzen will
sich mal auszusprechen richtig und ich
glaube es hat über drei Stunden gedauert
und dreieinhalb Stunden hat Joe Biden
gesagt ich lese drei Stunden aber ich
weiß nicht ob das ist schon bedeutend
und dann hat mir ja nicht vergessen die
beiden Herren kennen sich ja von früher
als sie beide
Vize
Vizepräsidenten waren beide viel zu
Präsidenten genau und das spielt
natürlich auch eine Rolle und beide
haben eigentlich doch eine ähnliches
Interesse weil man sagt ja so schön wenn
wenn China blockiert dann stehen hier
die fliesbänder still hier heißt in
Amerika aber auch in Deutschland ja ich
glaube vielleicht sollte man das auch so
sehen beide gegen gestärkt sind in das
Treffen sind also stark gehen in dieses
Treffen und können sagen wir haben hier
eine gemeinsame Verantwortung
ist stark weil Parteitag im Grunde
zugelassen hat dass sein Team also der
Ständige Ausschuss sind Politbüro
alles nur mit seinen Leuten besetzt
Essen so beiden hat ist gestärkt durch
diese
zwischenbahnen aber die ich kann mir
vorstellen der Ping denkt gut ich habe
jetzt einen eine Partei die mich stützt
aber
wie steht es eigentlich mit dem
Versprechen einer stabilen Wirtschaft
und einer sich entwickelnden Wirtschaft
also es ist klar dass die Pink von einer
funktionierenden Weltwirtschaft abhängig
ist und er kann schon rein von seinem
Interesse her diesen Krieg nicht wollen
und er sieht auch wie so ein angeblicher
Freund und Partner Russland geschwächt
immer weiter geschwächt wird welche
Rolle spielt Olaf Scholz oder was wie
läuft es für ihn für Deutschland
da gibt es ein eine interessante Abfolge
ich weiß nicht wie man die
interpretieren kann wir haben ja auch
ist ganz wichtig
in der Erklärung eine Verurteilung von
der Drogen mit Nuklearwaffen
das wäre jetzt das dritte mal wo das
geschieht und obwohl der Name Russland
nicht drin steht der 7 klar das Russland
gemeint ist und das letzte Mal war beim
Besuch unseres Bundeskanzlers in Peking
und davor in Sommerkamp bei der Treffen
der Shanghai Organisation also hier gibt
es ist der Bundeskanzler quasi in eine
Reihe von ganz bewussten
Schritten dabei seine Reiseziele sind
auch interessant
er war in Vietnam jetzt in Singapur und
zwei Dinge aber zum Treffen des Asien
pazifikausschuss der deutschen
Wirtschaft der Deutschland ist die große
Frage
die aber schon beantwortet eigentlich
ist koppeln wir uns ab von China oder
die visifizieren wir ja
und die Antwort ist wir koppeln uns
nicht ab hier diese diversifizieren aber
wir bleiben mit China genau
so formulieren und über diese
verifizieren und wir haben ja auch die
Verhandlung der EU mit Indien von
Handelsabkommen mit Vietnam ist es
glaube ich jetzt abgeschlossen also die
Diversifizierung ist glaube man hat den
richtig und sie ist im vollen Gang ganz
herzlichen Dank für diese Einschätzungen
hier live bei uns in Phoenix Studio
gerne danke